I applied to a 100 jobs in five days and
this is how. Hi, my name is Nia. I'm the
black female engineer. I provide content
for you and aspiring software engineers
and let's get right into it cuz the job
market ain't it and it's not going away
for nobody. So, how to apply to 100 jobs
in just 5 days. The first thing you're
going to want to do is think about your
role, your ideal role, but also think
about based on your past experience, all
the other roles that you could apply to.
If you're scrolling on the job board and
you saw a role for let's say front-end
developer when really your role is UX
developer, would you think to apply to
it? If your answer is yes, write that
role down. Now, write down all the roles
that this applies to. For me that is
software engineer, front-end engineer,
UX developer, and iOS/mobile
developer engineer. You want to aim for
at least three different roles. Once you
have those written down, go onto a job
board. I love using LinkedIn and type in
the role. So for me, I'll start by
typing in software engineer. Now, the
first 10 roles to pop up that are
reasonably within my qualifications. So,
the ones that say 10 plus years of
experience, maybe I won't include those.
The first 10 roles that appear, copy
everything from what you'll do on the
job to required qualifications and then
preferred qualifications. Open up some
doc, whether it be Google doc, Microsoft
doc, notes, pages, whatever. Open up
some doc, write job one, and copy and
paste those roles onto that document.
Now go to the second job that appeared
with that title, and do the same exact
thing. Do the same thing for 10 jobs.
Once you have your document full of 10
jobs, the key responsibilities,
expectations, preferred skills, and
whatnot, go over to chat GPT and say the
following. Please provide me a ranked
list of key skills needed for these
blank roles. For me, that would be
software engineering roles. Now,
depending on your job, this may look a
little different. And so, I'm going to
do it based on tech, but I'm sure you
will see how to fill it in. So for me I
would say please provide me a ranked
list of the most common technologies
that were requested. Then I'll ask
please provide me a ranked list of the
most common languages that were
requested. And then finally I'll ask
please provide me a ranked list of the
most common skills that were requested.
Once it outputs the result for all of
those questions, use that to fully
optimize your resume. For me, right at
the top, I put in things like languages,
technologies, and other. And so, I
provide the exact things that chat said
were in their top rankings, provided
that I somewhat know it or know it very
well. But if it's over here asking for C
sharp and I don't know anything about
that, I'm not going to put it in. But I
can go refer back to the other languages
and tech it said were in the top
rankings. Then use the top skills
mentioned to populate the meat of your
resume. It'll be amazing if you can
combine these two, the technologies and
languages with the skills. something
like leverage JavaScript to update the
company's most recent user profile pages
resulting in user satisfaction increase
of 30%. Something like that. You know
what I mean? Once you are done doing
that for your first role, again we're
using software engineer. Do it again and
again and again for all of the job roles
you had previously written down. This
will take some time. Yes. However, it is
only going to save you in the long run.
Once you have all of your résumés,
again, like three to five of those
résumés, when you go into your job
board, you can specifically ask for the
role per the resume you're going to
apply with. So now I can say, you know
what, Tuesday, I'm going to focus
primarily on mobile developer roles. So
I'm going to go in and say mobile
developer in jobs because again, I'm
using LinkedIn and just apply to all of
those. Now, because I use chat to help
me see what were the top most likely
skills and languages being asked for,
honestly, I'm only going to look at the
years of experience needed. And if it's
at least somewhere in my ballpark, I'm
applying to it. I'm no longer going to
swift down the details about, oh, they
are they asking for this and is a good
match and no. If it's five or less years
of experience wanted slash needed, I am
going to apply to it immediately. That
is the only thing I'm looking at from
now on. I'm saying five because I have
three to four years of experience but
depending on what we include. And so if
you let's say have zero experience, I
wouldn't do anything more than three
years of experience because based on
your portfolio projects, you may be at
the level of someone with three years of
experience. Number two, the way to apply
to as many jobs as possible is by
getting away from the job boards. You'll
want to do this instead. On top of
applying to job boards, what you'll also
want to do is head over actually to
LinkedIn. No matter what job board you
use, go, and this isn't sponsored, by
the way. I just I love LinkedIn. um go
onto LinkedIn and not on their job
board, but go and search hashtag hired
in their search bar because companies
from what I hear need or at least
sometimes need to pay to be on the
official LinkedIn job board. The ones
who can't afford to or just simply don't
want to pay for it, simply post about
the jobs that are available at their
companies and trust that their networks
will uplift the post. So, in the search
bar, type #hiring. You may want to add
in other keywords to make things more
specific for you and just, you know,
increase the chances of getting the role
that you specifically are looking for.
So you can also say #hiring
and in capital letters quotes the role
software engineer, software developer,
iOS developer, etc. Now you can scroll
through all the different posts of
people, managers, recruiters, etc.
looking to hire people but aren't
putting it on the job boards. Now you
have jobs that are in the job boards and
jobs that are not. Really just applying
wherever you see is a good fit and
increasing your odds of getting that
call back. Number three, know the best
time to apply. The best time to apply
according to recruiters themselves is
the end of the week or very beginning of
the week. So, Friday, Saturday, Sunday,
Monday. This is because recruiters will
add new job postings for the weekend
slash early Mondays. That way, they can
log on to work on Monday and see who has
applied and now the rest of the week is
filled with calling people in for
interviews. If you don't apply until
Wednesday, by then that recruiter has
spent two days interviewing people and
seeing them off to second interviews and
then third interviews and then an offer.
So likely the person who is going to get
the job is the person that applied
before the recruiter even logged on.
With this, not only are you applying to
jobs as they come in, but you're also
amongst the first to apply to jobs,
which again in this economy can just
make all the difference. Now, before you
log off, make sure you do these things.
One, every single time you apply to a
job, no matter where it is or when it
is, put it into some type of tracker.
Either create a tracker on like Excel or
Sheets or find one online. I'm sure
there's many. You can also download a
tracker that I've made in the
description box below, completely free.
Just make sure that you create your own
copy, okay? Or else you won't be able to
do nothing with it. We're not doing this
just for kicks and giggles. This is
extremely important because we want to
know where things are maybe falling off
for us. Are we not getting interviews?
If we're not getting interviews at all,
something needs to be tweaked with our
resume. Are we getting the interview but
not getting the second interview or the
final offer? Well, then that means our
resume is fantastic. So, don't touch
that. However, let's work on your
interview skills. Knowing that is
extremely important. So, make sure you
track your jobs. And two, try to apply
whenever you can. Because I optimize for
my resume for the specific role I'm
applying to, I don't even read the
description anymore. So because of that,
I'm able to apply while I'm watching TV
or while I'm waiting for people or while
I'm on the phone and things like that.
I'm able to do it pretty effortlessly
now. And it is now just a whole routine
for me, allowing me to get to that 100
job number pretty quickly. And when
we're seeing over and over that 100 plus
applicant number for each job we're
applying to, having a 100 plus jobs
applied to seems quite necessary right
now. So, let's just do what we can to
get to that number in a smart way that
will actually get us a job. And finally,
please, please, please give this video a
big thumbs up and subscribe so that you
can see more tips and also see me on my
journey as I get a job in the next two
months. Thank you so much for watching
and I'll talk to you very soon.